each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning everybody it's my great
pleasure to have Paris Magnus and
bhiksha arrived here from Mitsubishi
Electric research labs I've known big
chef for quite a while now since I think
1998 when we shared an office at CMU and
I've known Paris for a while too since
pretty much since picture I got tomorrow
and started working with Paris so
they're going to we've sort of gonna
have a tag team presentation today two
parts of the same talk first half by
Paris and then by bhiksha so without
further ado here's Paris thanks so
you've been staring at this light for a
long while so no need to elaborate on
the title and Pirus is mike said so i'll
be doing the first half of the talk i'll
mostly slow astro interesting demos and
stuff get you more psyched about what
we're doing and then Victor is going to
tell you all the deeper stuff so he's
kind of an overview of the talk i'm
going to give you some motivation why we
did this type of work and what's the
reasons behind it and then i'm going to
talk about pls a which is a very
interesting decomposition algorithm and
then show some to shift in various
versions of for it it's probably not
clear to you right now what that means
but hopefully you'll get it by by the
end of the talk so motivation a lot of
the signals that Miss I consider fun
tend to be positive so I'm an audio guy
I use a lot of audio spectra they're
always positive images also have a
tendency to be positive valued text
sometimes is a positive but when you
usually take like a machine learning
course or some pattern recognition
course first thing to learn about is PCA
and then you might learn about ICA or
other types of dimensionality reduction
techniques whether can find some
structure and there's no you don't
usually see a constraint that the data
is going to be positive and the problem
with that is that you end up having lots
of with artifacts because of that well
we have a bunch of character numbers at
least in my in my way of dealing this
text
hmm so here's an example which I think
kind of describes this very well so
these are pictures from what's called
again faces so it's a PCA analyses on a
bunch of faces it was groundbreaking
work when it came out and it still very
it's still very efficient when it comes
to classifying and doing stuff like that
but there's a bit of a problem this is
what PCA is going to find a structure in
a face database and even though it's
great for classification you can
probably tell that this things don't
really correspond to something that we
will find interesting in the face we
have all these weird ghostly images they
are images that also assume negative
values which we're not sure how to
actually translate to something
meaningful and it's not satisfying the
sense so this is one of the things we're
going to try to address how do we deal
with positive data and the other thing
is what would happen if those faces were
actually in debate the database worships
had left and right up and down in this
example you had somebody set people up
everything was aligned and nice that's
not always the case in the real world so
these are the two things you want to
focus on so our objective is going to be
first to develop a nice transform what
we don't you really use cross
cancellations to superimpose a bunch of
bases and get something when i Kenned up
with components that are actually
meaningful to us and the second thing is
we want to have invariance when
things move around we want to
automatically deal with that we don't
want to have to actually align
everything by hand just a very brief
overview of what people have done before
there's the principle independent
component analysis and like very very
basic bread and butter stuff when it
comes to machine learning basically just
a simple linear transform you have this
random vector X you want to find some
linear decomposition of it so that you
get some properties in the output and
PCA wants to get orthogonal outputs I
say wants to get independent outputs
huge list of applications people have
used it for a lot of things and they
work very well but again that don't
really deal with positive data nmf was
an algorithm that was introduced in 99 I
think I by alien sunk and they sort of
address this problem what happens if you
want to decompose something which is
non-negative values and what they did is
actually something that's very similar
to PC a nice
yay they said all we have this matrix
over here H I'm sorry this matrix X so
we want to serve decompose it as a
product of two other matrices but
everything has to be non-negative and
when they did that they found out that
you can actually come up with some very
very interesting components things
didn't end up being those weird ghost
images you saw in the faces they
actually ended up extracting I just one
component and noses and stuff like that
the learning goals rule that they used
were extremely sexy because they were
very efficient they convert very
converts very fast unfortunately nobody
has a clue why they work I'm not sure
the authors do either but oops that's
recorded shouldn't say that but one big
problem with this approach is that it's
not really a probabilistic framework if
you want to take this thing and plug it
into an hmm or plug it into some in an
SVM or something like that you have no
idea how to actually get probabilities
out of it and that has kind of turned
people off when it came to NM f so we're
going to start whoops we're going to
start this stuff that I'm going to talk
about now from the probabilistic latent
semantic analysis that was another
rhythms of which originally developed
for a text analysis by hoffman like 99
and it's basically a probabilistic
version of what you offer the SPD
essentially you want to find
correlations between words or letters or
whatever you people used to do is with
this for that Hoffman did this in a
probability space by using the pls a and
what it does is actually very simple you
have a joint distribution P of X you
want to break this down into a sum of
marginals so you have a bunch of
marginals on the x axis you have a bunch
of marginals on the y-axis you multiply
them you get this joint distributions
you want to have a bunch of those and be
add them together to approximate your
the distribution your you you want to
model and this is all of course
conditional and latent variable the way
that that was introduced was in a 2d
setting it's pretty straightforward to
actually come up with a
multi-dimensional generalization we
basically have more marginal to being
multiplied so no big deal there probably
don't want to spend too much time on how
you estimate this day
it's fairly straightforward en training
you end up having a pretty simple Estep
then somewhat simple m-step and the
thing that I want to highlight here is
that you know you can go through the e/m
derivation and at the end you get two
things which with some algebraic
manipulation end up being the same as
the nmf multiplicative rules yes I think
column in the two papers in one of them
it was called pls I and the other one
pls a so it's a later probabilistic
latent semantic indexing and then
analysis so if you're doing tech stuff
you care about indexing if you're just
decomposing stuff you call it analysis
so at least as far as I know there's no
difference as far as I know yeah so one
interesting point here which I'm serve
not going to elaborate at all is that
the whole nmf thing was actually a
version of this the non-negative matrix
factorization so it was the second
transfer my show before you're talking
about Matty the sameness it's medically
exact same thing only this one so in the
matrix on the non-negative matrix stuff
you were decomposing a matrix so it was
explicitly two-dimensional in this case
or distribution that we model can be a
multi-dimensional distribution so you're
essentially doing a non-negative tensor
decomposition as opposed to a matrix so
it gives you much more flexibility and
can actually derive likelihoods and
stuff like that which is always a good
thing okay so enough month here's an
example now so suppose that we start
with this distribution here so we have
three gaussians one big fat goes in down
here and to lose thing ones over here
what happens if we do pls i on that
thing so we're going to get in this case
we wanted a decomposition of in terms of
30 we had the latent variables from
three different values so we would get
three marginals on the x axis three
marginals on the y axis and then three
numbers which are the briars of each
marginal yes said so what we get here is
that these are the marginals from the
up/down axis so you can see that the
first marginal here pretty much
describes the profile of this Gaussian
and then this equivalence profile here
describes them
on this side and likewise you can model
the other to go she answers products of
these guys here and then you have the
Prioress and in the front of the
decomposition that tells you how much of
these gaussians is presence into the
distribution so if you basically
multiply this together and waiting by
this you get the approximation which is
essentially the same thing so we managed
to describe this probability
distribution in terms of a sum of
marginals so in that setting it's not
spectacularly amazing right i mean it's
a bunch of gaussians so let's see how we
can actually use those in more real life
signals so at the beginning i'm going to
show you some applications of pls a just
an audio so simple stuff so when people
deal with audio and they want to do
something complicated like recognition
or something like that usually the throw
phase away in the work on magnet
inspector and market inspector are
essentially some sort of a histogram it
tells you how many little time frequency
Adams hits every point in the
time-frequency playing it's like a
wavelet counter if you want so it's
essentially a distribution and we can
model that using pls a and since it's a
distribution of course is positive
everything works out fine so i'm going
to show you examples have two examples
one of how to how we can do separation
of sources and the object discovery and
then something noising as well so here's
the simple case so we have a nice little
sound seen let me see if i can play that
trick back to the 80's so it's a bunch
of drums this is the time-frequency
representation of that sound it's in log
scale so it's more easy to see so you
can if you kind of look at it you can
kind of identify different instruments
in there so we have the cowbell which is
that harmonic looking thing over here
let me have the club for the snare drum
which is this big wide band thing here
you have the base ground which is all
this energy down here this doesn't serve
the sounds that we want to make up the
scene now if we do a pls a on that
distribution went up getting some very
interesting results so on the on the
marginals describing the frequency
domain we get stuff like something
that's very peaky the low end which is
essentially the bass drum
or we get something that has all these
harmonic peaks which is essentially the
little cowbell here or you get this wide
band thing which is the clapping or the
snare drum and the corresponding pair
over here it tells you how much that
particular spectral profile is going to
appear across time so we can say that
okay we have this wide band thing here
and it appears at this point and at this
point so we've essentially modeled this
blob over here which ends up
corresponding to an instrument and of
course if you know this sketch where
matrix as a distribution so it's a joint
distribution of time and frequency for
pls say i haven't you follow the blsa
hmm if it was I would say it would have
been a matrix yes so you do we need to
our singular value decomposition yeah
you actually most people to dig up you
know the components that has if I want
to do singular value decomposition then
these things would be the orthogonal
basis on one side and this would be the
basis of the other side but the SVD with
screw things up because it would try to
use cross cancellation to describe
everything so instead of getting nice
things which describe activities exactly
the way I want it you would get things
that cancel out that would be orthogonal
which would be kind of it's kind of an
admitting well it's kind of a
meaningless meaningless constraint when
it comes to those things it would
describe the same energy in a sense but
it wouldn't give me the results I want
things would be mixed up my
understanding of all Oh LSA versus PSA
test application I feel that every
single teach other people never claimed
that one moves in yellow oh uh I haven't
used it on the text space too much it
came here to be in the talking about the
discretion he's a while but madam the
functionality is here and what we're
looking at is the semantic zone ah in an
acoustic sense what do you mean we're
negative power spectrum there is no such
thing as a negative power structure so
if you just did LSA then the base is
that you would
building blocks i'm going to have
positive and negative confidence and so
if you thought of each of the basis as a
sound they're going to get a sound which
has positive like your energies and
negative electric i have totally
meaningless and so you know as a result
you're not going to get anything that
actually I satisfies to something for
somatic one does it contain essentially
what he's trying to say is if you want
to pick up a generative model haha pls
is a generator monster LSA it not also
and I see is the optimal d function that
you're optimizing in these two cases are
different lsi you're trying to have a
low level representation which minimizes
the Euclidean distance the
representation was just original data
here is the probability of generation
that's this so you think about pls a as
a constraint our saying by making things
positive now not necessary you know I
think there's a lot of stuff that's
hidden under the rug right now so I
think big show is going to elaborate
more on that yeah so now we have a bunch
of spectral profiles we have a bunch of
temporal profiles we can basically
combine them and actually extract just
the sound that we want out of the
mixture so if we do that with one pair
we get this which is the thing is the
bass drum so we have this low energy
thing which describe bass drum and then
what's another one this is going to be
the hi-hat so and then we get the
cowbell and what is the hand laps so
we've essentially managed to grab out of
this make sure all the components that
were present yes you assume you know how
many components are there in advance yes
so that's like a universal problem when
it comes to dimensionality reduction
direct how many components we extract
did you have to how many times did he
have to run it for you to get this kind
of decomposition or does it produce the
same way my sins lsi produces different
decomposition time and you can end up
having mixed models I mean sometimes I
was I will put it on text for example
hmm very often I get mixed topics which
don't be much anyway
on pegs you typically get all kinds of
meat stuff and you have to work very
hard and you actually use your brains to
make it too what are the difference here
is that yeah we differentiate between
you have a lot of data you have a lot of
data in very few correlations so this is
a huge amount of data compared to the
text document and you only have five or
six things happening in there so you
have a lot of information pointing at
the right direction in text you don't
really have as much structure and that's
what makes a difference in this case
then in my experience I mean especially
in this example you always get the same
answer you might get a perm you dated
answer which doesn't change anything zun
see there's no there's no distribution
assumption mr. Graham yes look like it
wavelet that we represent it what you
still have the time any other faces um
well you know short-time fourier
transform wavelet it's called kind of
the same thing you're just thinking in a
different grid after you do this
analysis you still come up with color
braces and yes so it will be a special
case it was an extra neck it's an extra
level of decomposition on top of the
frequency the conversation so this thing
can actually be general about can be
sort of extended to even more
complicated stuff probably shouldn't
spend too much time on that but it can
actually do that with like do canto
music transcription every piano note in
a piece of music is going to have a
different spectral that profile you can
actually learn an entire piece of music
you can pretty much know how many notes
that are and then what you end up
getting as the temporal weight is where
each kind of node was located so here's
an example of a Bach fugue and go guess
you can see the lines
what you see here is basically how much
each node was was active at any time at
any point in time and you can't have to
take my word for it pretty much
identifies all of the notes stop so it
pretty much identified all of the nodes
I think it only made like one mistake
and it offers a pretty nice
decomposition of the entire music piece
okay so that was an example where we had
unsupervised learning on spectra I had a
spectrum I said okay give me that many
components and then that ended up being
meaningful and you're probably thinking
right now okay if I start speaking with
something there's not one spectrum that
describe my voice things change all the
time it's not such an easy thing how do
we deal with that so in that case we
actually have to move to a supervised
strategy what we can do now is we can
actually learn the spectra that describe
a particular type of sound and then when
we encounter that sound in the mixer or
in some other situation we can actually
see how much though spectra exist in
that mixture and that's great for
denoising or extracting a speech out of
stuff so here's an example so let's
let's focus on the spectrogram over here
so this is a thing a male male speaker
and he has some sort of chimes for
playing in the background limply the
sound as well so you get an idea that
the morning dew on the spiderweb glisten
in the Sun okay pretty noisy so you
might notice that if you sort of look at
things on the frequency axis the chimes
have a pre specific spectral pattern
right they don't really interfere so
much with the speaker they don't sort of
moving the same frequency space the
speaker on the other side ends to be
then to have a lot of energy down here
he doesn't have all these straight lines
going through spectrally they're very
different sounds so if we online have a
model where we trained on how chines
sound like and sort of keep a database
of that of their of their marginal
distributions in the frequency axis and
do the same thing for the speaker once
we have a mixture of those two sounds we
can try to analyze it based on those
marginals and then see which one exists
where and then we can do a
reconstruction or
let's try to reconstruct the entire
thing what we don't really we don't
really synthesize with the time to in
there we're just going to use the
speaker or we only going to use a chime
frequencies so here's a couple of
examples this is an example where we
have thing a female speaker with silly
noise citrine noisy offline we've
learned the model for that female
speaker we also have a model for the
noise if we do reconstruction where we
only use the frequency distributions for
the female speaker we get this and I
don't know what you want to do that but
you can also get the noise as well and
here's the example with the chimes as
well if it please the morning dew on the
spiderweb glistened in the first so
that's the mixture the morning dew on
the spiderweb glistened in the third now
one thing that yeah I see how you can
your model to save the chimes with male
presented but how do you learn the voice
of the person it's not like the voice
has pics patterns and you know you
either stay or or you cetera maybe a
very very big mobile so yeah for this
one I think I used about 80
distributions to model the speaker so
the assumption is that whenever I say ah
it pretty much sounds the same all the
time and every word I say that uses the
phoneme ah it's probably going to use
the same distribution and that's going
to be sufficiently different from the
noise sources and that's what the
assumption is right now that I'm since
she and I sets generation mall what
problem that mess over here that
actually represent how comfortable you
have that yeah and I'm confused about
your method here are you using is
the pre-mixed audio recording of em
saying that to build your model or
speech I have different recordings of
the chimes and that speaker and then
once I have a mixture I try to explain
that make sure using the spectral
distributions of those two sources you
are using it as two separate separate ok
I'm not using the same sound and of
course as a side note if i have the same
speaker mixed with himself there's no
way you can separate that because they
have the same frequency profile generic
speech small me tray with several
different speakers still only that
speaker no not that I remember not like
so I think has the most speech
stuff with that so you can be with him
on that here's a more extreme de-noising
example this is so far recording it's a
soprano in a piano play the sound in a
moment and this is a slightly different
situation because now we can't really
get the soprano distributions anywhere
because she's always thinking with the
piano we only have a few snippets of in
the piece where the camera is playing by
itself so we can learn the distribution
of the piano but we can't we can't
really learn the distributions of the
soprano so that's a slightly different
methodology here in that we learn about
a bunch of distribution for the piano
and then we try to explain the mixture
with the can of distributions plus some
unknown onez and there no one's actually
end up tuning into the soprano because
that's a lot of a lot of the unexplained
signal and then the methodology room
that is pretty much the same so this is
the these are the extract that
spectrograms let me play this sounds as
well this is a mixture
and of course a problem that is that
when you do music you actually try to
synchronize a lot of your harmonic
content with the other instruments so
it's not as simple as having like noise
and speech it's slightly more hard so
let's the extracted piano and bush so
you can kind of hear the channel notes
that coincide with the soprano but the
ref is kind of filtered out because it
doesn't really have much relationship
yes yes is everything fades out yes so
at the end in there so over here the
piano is not extracted very well and the
reason for that is that the sopranos
that's having this was we'd rather hear
and she starts covering this huge in
between the notes yeah silence oh that's
because the channel starts dominating
that part and it starts stealing a lot
of energy from the soprano and again a
lot of those things are not very easy to
understand why the work that way so let
that happen to be the best approximation
in this case okay so i've talked about
audio a lot right now and of course one
thing we all know is that audio has a
lot of times track yes i'm still when
you say best approximation in what sense
so we have a distribution which is the
spectrogram of the mixture and we're
trying to approximate that using the
marginals on the frequency axis that we
have learned before offline so we want
to find which of them the marginals on
the time axis that would best describe
that make sure given the known given the
knowledge err on the frequency domain
that we have carries some perceptual
sense right ah well not the results end
up being perceptually interesting as
opposed to what you would get using an
SVD for example i mean i can't claim
that this is how the brain works or
anything like that but i mean if you do
pc and a spectrogram and actually hear
the results what you're going to get
something like
which mathematically is might be
beautiful but it doesn't make much sense
and I guess that's the point I'm trying
to make yep you're you're assuming that
the spectrograms are edited right yes
yeah that isn't always true do you think
that there's anything to be done there
causing any problems for you so yes that
is a very strong assumption i'm making
on average that's an okay assumption it
seems to work fine people have shown
that even if you start masking things in
and out and sort of have a binary match
that you impose you can still get
something that sounds good so even if
you don't believe I'd activity you can
at least believe that you have some
exclusivity on a particular time
frequency spot we try to try thinking of
ways of itself dealing with that you can
actually start raising things to powers
where things might become a little
better or not we haven't played too much
with it at least in terms of results
we've been thinking about it but it
doesn't seem to be a big stumbling block
at the moment it's definitely becomes a
problem when you have something like 20
sources added together because then you
actually start having a lot of cross
cancellations but then again if you add
two sounds together things are going to
get cancelled out anyway and you can
really model that you can't make up
information I will see something
important here so you had a little model
how do you synthesize once you get the
generative model because I don't see how
you get the relative strengths of the
sounds at different levels do you have
to take that out of the equation and put
it back in later so in the m-step of am
training I had an update rule for the
marginals on one side and then I
learning rule for the marginals on the
other side what I do is I assume that I
already know the marginal zone the
frequency axis and only trained on the
marginals from the time axis and i think
yet this week is going to go to that but
i'm basically clamping the frequency
domain stuff as it is in trying to see
what's the best time distributions to
model what I have do usually the
original face and I'm using the original
phase to make an audible decomposition
so audio has a lot of time structures it
would be really nice if we could model
little snippets of sound as opposed to
just modeling a single spectrum like I
said before when I speak I don't have
like this five different spectrums I use
all the time actually have little fun
amex phonetic structures I use all the
time it would be really nice if I could
model that so the extension to that is
pretty straightforward that's the ideal
equation for those who like integrals
that's the more elegant one essentially
what we're going to do now is we're
going to say we still haven't a
summation of a bunch of products but the
products are going to be convolutions so
I'm going to have what we call a general
distribution which can be an entire
patch of a distribution and that's going
to be convoked with what I call an
impulse distribution and that's going to
position that left and right and where I
want it if this convolution if the
length of the Colonel's go was going to
be 1 then essentially this gets demoted
to a straight toward pls a best way to
describe this is nothing to give you a
little Gaussian example so imagine that
we have this distribution over here if
you think if you look at it long enough
you'll notice that we have one version
looking at the top right which repeats
three times here and then once more over
here and then we have two other
gaussians which form a little wedge and
they repeat once here and once here so
we have the same distribution gets
repeated on the left-right axis in some
random way if we do this type of
analysis we're essentially going to try
to find a bunch of kernels that
duplicate on this axis and if we train
the way of the convoluted pls a we can
get a kernel which looks like this which
is actually with one repeating component
the other one looking like this and then
the impulse distribution is going to
describe how these candles are going to
be placed on the left-right axis so the
interpretation here is that we have the
wedge here it repeat it appears once and
there's a pause then it appears twice
which is the case here and then we have
the single Gaussian it appears three
times in a row then small pause then
once again so it's three times in a row
pause once again so now we've modeled
some of the shifting variants on the
left-right axis in the probability
distribution space
does it make sense may be quite
different from the previous one because
you now one of your objects is not
something that's one month yes so now
we've kind of extended the idea of using
multiplication of marginals to using a
convolution of distribution another
series of impulses only thing is you
have this one slice cannot cut anywhere
now you see how this patch could occur
anywhere essentially it's the same thing
you're just taking your bases and
stretch them out in time it'll start
making more sense when I go to images
and stuff like that boring math it works
out don't worry about it so like I said
we're going to learn patches of
distributions so that's useful in audio
because we have things that often repeat
in time as entire segment as little
snippets of sounds same thing for images
we have things that shift left and right
like characters it also works well so
here's a more pictorial example when you
have an image you can always think of it
as a distribution as well you have the
probability that a specific that a
photon hits a particular XY spot right
so here's an example of some characters
I have no idea what this says I hope
it's not offending so we have a bunch of
characters we assume that this is a
distribution and if your eyes are sharp
enough you can probably notice that this
character gets repeated once here this
guy gets repeated over here and then
this one just happens by itself if we
try to analyze this distribution using
the regular pls a model it would have to
model it as a summation of marginals and
there's no way in hell that those things
could be approximated by a by a couple
of marginals they're very complicated
shapes if we do the convoluted case we
can ask for something about that wide
that appears on the left-right axis and
if we do that we end up extracting three
bases which are these three which are
actually whoops well uploaded that in
Reverse so ok pretend that's reversed so
these are the characters over here and
then we're going to get the impulse
distributions which are going to tell us
how those things are positions so if we
take this character
here it only gets a spike in the middle
because it only appears here if we take
this character it has a spike at the
beginning because it's the first one and
that one at the end because it's also
the last one so now we've modeled a
fairly complex distribution if you like
and miners deal with shifting left and
right slightly more realistic or real
world scenario is this recording one one
two one two one so that's me saying one
and then saying to on top of that so if
you can contrast that with the case
before it's the same speaker pretty much
have the same spectral profile but I do
have this bunch of repeating snippets of
sounds that are shifted in time if you
do a pls a analysis on that we're going
to get a spectrum info two components
we're going to get a spectrum for every
word if you like and we get crappy
results like this
but if you actually try to find an
entire patch of a distribution that
repeats in time we get more interesting
stuff 1111 to select the noise as well
so i hope this kind of makes sense of
the convoluted operation we have this
thing which repeats over time a lot and
cannot find out where it appears yes
verify do you know how many tributes are
there really triggers I would have yeah
so this is equivalent I need to know the
dimensionality of my problem character
example in that 1i I specifically asked
for three characters yes different
configurations but um I could have asked
for 18 characters and then you would
actually start getting elements that get
repeated and that sort of goes back to
finding the property may serve dimension
for your problem which as far as I know
and nobody has solved effectively it's
kind of like finding the dimensionality
when you have a piece a problem you know
what's the right one nobody knows I 30
depends on your problem word 10 sleepy D
or was it said twice it was said I
turned on the microphone and said 11 11
and then said twice twice twice it put
22 on top of that so it wasn't it wasn't
yes it wasn't identical it was different
so we looked at very large scale for a
sort of objects right now you know what
is a pretty significant chunk of time
with Reese for speech what happens when
we start thinning down that Colonel
window and start looking at smaller
things let me start getting very
interesting stuff so this is there these
are the extracted kernels from just
analysis of some timid speech and what
we start seeing here is that we start
seeing some harmonic structure we sing
some maybe consonants over here we see
little snippets of sounds that actually
describe a lot of the speech structure
and what's very interesting in that is
that it changes depending on the speaker
so these are a bunch of Carol's we
extracted from a female speaker and you
can see the harmonic structure here it
maybe have some consonants which are all
the noisy patches over there now if you
trust that with a male speaker you'll
see that it's different the male speaker
has a lower fundamental frequency the
harmonics are more clustered together
the female has a higher fundamental
frequency things are going to be more
spread out and now the interesting part
is that if I have if I analyze a mixture
of male and female speech I get some of
both so I get some like this here we
could belong to the male speaker low
frequency clustered harmonics this one
belong to the female speaker so we kind
of have a then is going to
elaborate more than that but we can have
like a an interesting insight on how we
could construct a scene where to speak
to known speakers speaking at the same
time it's constructed out of little
patches from different from the two
speakers and if we sort of acted on that
assumption we can say okay let's learn
something about one speaker find out
phonemes learn something about the
second speaker in the phone into that
speaker and then if we have a mixture of
those two speakers let's try to explain
that scene using the candles I've
learned from both speakers and see how
and then try to do a reconstruction
using only the kernels from a single
speaker and if you do that you actually
get interesting results so this is one
of the better sounding examples so I've
trained offline on those two speakers
speaking different sentences so this is
the reconstruction using only the female
kernels chain make more money by working
apart and the male reconstruction the
less we could carry an oily rag like
that now if i had the same speaker
speaking on himself obviously this
wouldn't work because all the kettle's
would describe pretty much all the
energy so the more different speakers
are the better and this is a case where
you had a very sort of resonant male
voice and then the female was very damp
a high-frequency speaker if you have two
male speaker is not going to sound this
good for example how many cards you have
a speaker for this one it was probably
40 or 80 or something you don't want to
use too many candles because then you
end up describing too much detail which
means that you can actually describe a
lot of other speakers as well so there's
always that sweet spot which I don't
have a nice analytic way of finding out
so um when you would when you would say
one and two and they're mixed earlier
you can separate them much better than
here I presume that's because there was
reported to you saying one over and over
again that's the main difference that
was a cleaner case because I was it was
an unsupervised case I was trying to
find the structure in that particular
distribution in this case I'm trying to
explain the mixture using prior
knowledge from other recordings so I
actually had to fit my frequency by
valuable kernels into the mixture so
things are not going to fit that well as
clustering on the training data itself
this is extrapolating from some training
data to test area which is always harder
so what is the duration of the kernels
yeah I think it was a 88 time slices
which time slice but I think was a 512
point of 50 and the sampling rate was
about 16 k in the reconstruction is just
a concatenation and the reconstruction
is basically I'm I'm trying to
reconstruct the scene using only the
candles of every speaker and then using
the original phase of the mixture so I'm
modulating the phase of the mixture
using the amplitude convoluted mark yeah
it's not just one after the other the
basic goal mixed together according to
what my fitting way swear okay so if you
do images it's kind of obvious right now
what's coming next we want to do two
dimensional stuff so you just add
another tea and everything still works
out the same blah blah blah math no need
for that there's a minor complication
when you start moving to the 2d case
which is I it's not clear what becomes
an impulse in what becomes a colonel so
if you sort of think back in the
character example I said I have these
little patches that replicates left and
right if those had enough freedom to
replicate up and down as well I would
basically be convulsion to images now
which one would end up being the
character and which one would end up
being the little impulse it's not
something that's predefined it could be
either one so we need to find a way
where we can ensure that the training is
going to give us a lot of stuff or a lot
of energy on the kernels and as little
energy as we can on the impulse
distributions the proper way to do it is
to ask for a very low very high entropy
very low entropy on the impulse
distribution the math is very hairy
we've done it we're doing it actually
the easy way around it is to just add a
little step in leader in the EMA
training and just basically raised into
a power less than one lays the kit raise
the camera listen to a power less than
one that's going to force them to be
more more flat have much more energy in
the and eventually end up psyching up a
lot of the energy and leaving the
buses as a the impulse distribution is
having more impulsive and then you can
start having will have that power
tending towards one as you finish
training so things are clean again go
see an example simple stuff which that
with this input distribution there's a
basically two different types of
gaussians working in different ways this
car to the lower if we do the analysis
wind up getting these two kernels and
then these are the impulse distributions
that describe where those things should
have been placed we can move the
slightly more complicated example where
we have this handwriting over here again
we can do the same thing we can ask for
candles about that size and if we do
that these end up being the colonel
distributions obviously correspond to
the letters here and then I don't know
if you can see that very clearly these
are the impulse distributions can
basically basically have little dots
that describe where each letter was
present and the nice side effect of that
is that it makes my handwriting look
more uniform we can talk about three
deconvolution we can have X Y and then
have an extra dimension which is going
to be your RGB and start shifting things
there as well so this is the original
input a bunch of heads if we did the
analysis and look for one component then
it actually ends up being a nice color
phase in a very spooky reconstruction of
that and then we get lots of energy
where each phase was located so you can
can actually apply this into all sorts
of dimensionalities and it's usually
fine if you are into DSP this kind of
start standing into positive the
confirmation which is one of those
problems that has many solutions but
nobody has come up with a good solution
yet to my knowledge what we're trying to
do is figure out if you know that you
have something positive that gets
repeated over time if you do a regular
the convolution you're going to end up
having negative stuff in there the fully
transforms are going to do the
convolution operator is going to do that
for you which is pretty bad if you act
so you can actually use the same
technique or you fix the carrier all the
impulse depending on what you have into
the convolution and actually estimates
positive only components
probably not for you but astronomers
actually love that kind of stuff because
we usually have this convolution
happening on the stars and things like
that let me see a thing is give some
stuff and go into bhiksha so I've talked
about three different cases of pms a the
regular one that was known and then show
some extensions on the one deconvolution
and then multiple dimension convolution
and then some of the complications that
arrived so the message that I want to
leave you with is that non-
decompositions are useful because they
come up with things which are much more
interesting than a straightforward this
video or icy or something like that and
the other good thing is that now we have
a nice fiscal framework to deal to deal
with when it comes to non-
decompositions which we didn't have
before so you can start doing all sorts
of fancy stuff like stuffing this thing
into an hmm so you don't have to deal
with sectoral HMMs because they're going
to be additive ancient maps and stuff
like that so thanks for me and then
picture is going to take over and do
with this and questions are true then
just initialize randomly yeah there's
nothing special about it one thing that
I did yeah one thing that I didn't
mention is that you also have to specify
the size of the kettle distribution so
before you had to specify the
dimensionality of the problem now you
also have to specify how big you want
the kennel to be as well we have
incredibly I'd say yeah like in the face
example I asked for it for ya you made
this knowledge about putting strain on
the engine
it's different there is hard but you
were initiated but there is some work
that shows that exponentiating on the
end step is essentially cool they're
putting an intricate straight down
crucial after we actually have more
explicitly of doing same thing I was
this is just a first step right now and
it must be about you handling them to
beat cell end of my talk so then but I'm
not exactly picking up where Patterson
talk I will I kept a big step backward
and presenting everything from a
somewhat different perspective hopefully
this makes things a little clearer my
slides will be somewhat heavy on
metaphor a little thinner on results and
hopefully some interesting ideas will
begin with the idea of a multinomial
distribution we all know what a
multinomial distribution is if you have
a pot with lots of colored balls in it
and if someone were to draw balls from
this come from this urn then the
probability you're going to only get the
ball city pic are not only going to have
a limited number of colors namely the
colors they were already in the urn and
the probability of picking a ball of a
particular color only depends on the
fraction of balls in the NFL of that
color it's a common enough thing we've
learned about this in high school now
let's look at a power spectrum if you
compute the spectrum off a signal using
a discrete Fourier transform you're only
going to have a finite number of
frequencies in the spectrum and what the
power spectrum actually has is along the
x-axis it has the entire set of
frequencies and do we have a laser
I don't know this is
okay so you have along the x axis you
have frequencies along the y axis you
have the energy and you can actually
visualize this as a histogram beautiful
so much nicer isn't there anyway it's
nice to point with this I think it's the
x axis you can think of the x axis is
representing discrete events that could
happen and you connect you can think of
the y axis the energy as the number of
times this event occurred so you know
speaking of it and balling on terms you
can think of an urn which contains balls
and every ball has a frequency marked on
it and the person in generating a
spectrogram spectrum simply draws balls
from the Sun and then plots a histogram
of what happened and this would be the
model for our spectrum and this so this
is the entire procedure for generating a
spectrum of a signal now here's a
slightly more complicated model for
generating a spectrum the person doesn't
have just one on he has many ons and
each of the ions has balls with
frequencies marked on them except the
distribution of frequencies in any tuans
is different and not to generate a
spectrum what the person does is first
he selects and on and then he selects a
ball from the on notes the frequency and
eventually plots a histogram if this is
all he does been really there's no
difference between this model here and
this model here because you can simply
sort of munge all of these ions into one
single part and you'd get the same
spectrum but where things get
interesting is when we look at how the
person actually generates an entire
spectrogram now according to our model
the person has a number of parts runs
with freaked frequency mark balls in
them and in each time analysis frame now
before we begin what exactly the
spectrogram we know it's pretty good
time along the x-axis frequency along
the y-axis and every vertical slice over
here actually represents one frequency
which are one spectrum which has been
computed from one analysis
bring the color represents the height of
the spectrum of course so according to
this model within each analysis window
what the person does is to draw a number
of balls from the urns and plot the
histogram the point is the urns stay the
same for all analysis frames he doesn't
change the set of irons from analysis
frame to analysis frame the only thing
he changes is the manner in which he
selects the urns to generate to draw
balls and so the difference between the
spectra at different time instances
entirely explained by the relative
frequency differences in the relative
frequency with which he selects the arms
now the first example I showed was a
from simple multinomial a second example
is a mixture multinomial and in fact
multinomial xin mixture monton
multinomial are the same distribution
and the multinomial you'd have a given a
single probability term for generating a
particular outcome in a mixed in
multinomial the probability of a
particular outcome is going to be an
integral of the manner in which you're
going to select the particular
multinomial and the multinomial
dependent probability of that outcome
you just add these two up and if you
covered the process up with a big black
box and just thought of it as someone
sticking their hand into a box in
pulling out numbers then it wouldn't
matter whether whether there was one
part inside or 20 pots inside as far as
you're concerned with system multinomial
with one critical difference that the
mixture multinomial is very constrained
now if you have say three parts that
you're going to mix to generate a
particular multinomial each part has a
number of possible outcomes which you
can think of each of which has a
frequent probability so you could string
these probabilities out into a vector
and think of a probability vector and
this probability vector resides in some
probability space now if all the three
arms if all of your arms are independent
then the probability vectors would form
the corner of a simplex so if you have
only 3 3 earns the probability vectors
for the three urns will form a triangle
and any mixture multinomial that you
generate by combining these three
probability distributions is good is
also a probability vector
and it's guaranteed to lie within the
simplex and this is the constraint on a
mixture multinomial so when our mad
picker draws a spectrogram by drawing
part in our numbers from mixtures are
from combinations of parts what he
really does is that for each analysis
window he generates one spot from within
the simplex which is completely
identified by all the urns that he has
where each corner represents one of the
Earth's and in generating the entire
spectrogram all he is doing is sort of
generating a whole sequence of spots
through this simplex not we have the
model but how exactly would we estimate
the model we have a mixer multinomial
model for every frame we know that the
basic multinomial components do not
change from frame to frame but the
mixture weights by which these
multinomial is a combined change from
frame to frame and all we have observed
are the final outcomes the counts of the
various outcomes remember we are
thinking of the spectrum as the
histogram of counts over a discrete
random variable and well it turns out
you can do this very simply you can
simply use the expectation-maximization
algorithm all of us are familiar with it
if you sit down with a pen and paper I
am sure all of you could derive it the
graphical equivalent for the model is
you have a first level process which
selects and on a second level process
which selects a frequency from the urn
so this is the overall probability
distribution model for this for a
spectrum note that this is the
probability distribution that's supposed
to have generated a specific spectrum at
the teeth analysis frame this is a
combination of the probability
distributions for the individual urns
this is not a function of time this
stays constant and they are mixed by
these mixture weights which are the only
things that change from analysis frame
to analysis friend given this you can
come up with a set of simple update
equations which are extremely simple to
implement and really and how they I
don't need to go through them but you
can check them up in the slides if you
just implement these formulae you will
actually
estimate the distributions for the urns
and the mixture weight and every single
analysis for him now let's put this
model to work here as an example status
has shown you one example already
speaker separation is shown yeah he has
actually shown you multiple examples but
I'll expand on some of those and show a
couple of others bandwidth expansion
single channel speaker separation which
you can do in different ways you can
also incorporate prior knowledge into
the whole process something Paris is not
mentioned yet and this is something
sparse representation that something is
already alluded to and I'll explain it a
little more consider the problem of
bandwidth expansion now as I speak to
you over here I am actually generating a
lot of frequencies and generating
frequencies from zero hurts all the way
to about 120 kilo Hertz you can hear
everything between say 50 Hertz and 15
kilohertz and the reason my voice sounds
the way it does is because you hear
these really wide range of frequencies
but when you pick up a telephone you're
only going to get frequencies in the
range 300 Hertz to about 3.5 kilohertz
and the coin and the problem of
bandwidth expansion is given that you
only observed this specific set of
frequencies can you figure out what the
energy is where and other frequencies we
can look at this from the ball and on
perspective let's say that we know the
exact distribution of all frequencies in
the and all the urns that the speaker
uses to generate a spectrum and within
each other and he's got all frequencies
all the way from 20 Hertz to 15 15
kilohertz everything that we are
interested in and let's assume we also
know the relative frequencies with which
he picks his fix the aunts to select the
balls to generate your spectrum so in
other words we know everything about
this next year multinomial process that
actually generates the spectrum given
this say we only we are only allowed to
see some the histogram at some subset of
frequencies in the spectrum how can we
guess what the histogram was at other
points now this is you cannot think you
can sort of get or get an idea of just
from this very simplified example
let's say you had a pot which had only
three red and four blue balls and then
someone drew balls from the spot an
unknown number of times and you were
informed that in this process this
person has drawn exactly three red balls
then what is your best guess for the
number of blue balls that were drawn
from the pot it's easy enough to figure
but you know you can actually do it more
rigorously mathematically I am switching
metaphors here but that's only for this
one slight say think of a coin toss with
a with a fair coin now the probability
of generating say m heads in n thoses
would be given by this combinatorial
formula and so suppose I told you that
someone has started a cost and fair coin
say a hundred times no I don't tell you
how many times he has tossed it but I
tell you that a couple someone has
tossed a coin a certain number of times
and in this experiment he came up with
25 heads then what is your best guess
for the total number of tosses and if
you wanted a nice maximum likelihood
solution you would actually stick the
number 25 over here and compute this
term for various values of N and the
value of n at which it Peaks is your
best guess for the total number of
tosses and then once you have your best
guess for the total number of tosses you
can go one step back and actually figure
out how many tales he passed easy enough
if all you have our heads and tails but
if you have ten possible outcomes at 100
possible outcomes as you would in a in a
spectrum then this becomes a little more
complicated to compute but you can take
a simpler solution which is not which is
not exactly the same as the maximum
likelihood solution say you know that
the probability of heads is P heads here
and you know that he has got em heads
and the toss then you can estimate the
total number of tosses by just inverting
this so say for example if I told you
that it was a fair coin and that the
person has tossed 25 heads then it's
easy it's natural to assume that your
best guess for the total number of
tosses is 50 because heads occurs half
the time acha half the time and if you
had 50 tosses and you have 25 heads then
clearly you must have had 25 tails
simply given the entire mixture
multinomial distribution for a spectrum
now you can use the exact same
arithmetic to compute what the histogram
value was that all of the frequency is
given just some of these frequencies the
problem is you won't have all of it so
the procedure solution we will use to
expand the bandwidth of an arab and
solution is this from some training data
for the speaker we will actually learn
the ernst the multinomial list component
multinomial distributions for the
speaker then when you get some
narrowband data within each analysis
frame you're going to estimate how he
mixed those urns to come up with a final
histogram for the spectrum and then
having done that and then knowing
exactly what the spectrum was in its
frequencies that you have observed you
would compute the frequencies at other
the spectrogram at are the frequencies
now in order to compute the mixture
waits for the urns at each analysis
frame you have to ignore the frequencies
you did not see because in the narrow
band signal you are only going to be
looking at a narrowband signal and based
on the narrow band signal you have to
sort of estimate how he combined the
various arms and earns themselves
contain all frequencies so you would
have to ignore everything that you don't
see the mathematics again for this very
simple as before this is neither exactly
the same equations we had earlier with
one small difference that you're only
going to be integrating things I would
observed frequencies now once you have
actually computed the our entire process
the multinomial distribution you have
the ONS you have the mixture weights you
have the multinomial you have the band
limited signal so you can take the whole
thing back and compute the compiler
spectrum for the signal so here's an
example in this example here this is a
full band signal that I had began with
the plan raised a question in some minds
as to why the Union didn't propose to
acquire all of you al and then sell the
unrelated airline assets and I threw
everything about slightly below for kilo
Hertz or out of the sec
and based on and when you do that this
is what it sounds like the plan rates a
question in thumb mind as to why Adam
and Evan proposed to acquire all of you
a vision what I'll see undergo a better
one yeah I have actually reconstructed
are computed my best guess for the upper
bands and when you do that this is the
spectrogram you get you can see it
actually does a pretty good job of human
capturing things like fricatives even
fricatives which really don't have a lot
of energy in the lower frequencies and
if you listen to that it actually sounds
quite good the plan raised a question in
some minds as to why the Union didn't
propose to acquire all of you al and
then sell the unrelated airline asset it
sounds almost identical and raised a
question in some minds as to why the
Union didn't propose to acquire all of
you al and then sell the unrelated
airline assets versus lower banks
capture viewing the training of the
mixer way it from the yarmulke
multinomial distribution no but you're
nowhere to stress level primedia
talk so that probably go ahead alright
well each polynomial is going to have
the probability for each frequency I
think the trick here is the weight the
mixture is yes and a major way to be
done in time to handle man yeah and
that's yes and here on your fan yeah
right let me see over here open for
training wait I mean if the Mitchell
widget which sucks it's make sure you
know oh this is much easier to do
it no because it can you just just think
of this as having lots of mixture
multinomial where the basic multinomial
themselves are our shared the components
are shared parameters the mixture rates
are not so it's a very simple very
straightforward expectation-maximization
algorithm there's nothing to it he
doesn't I should have done Victoria t
minus one no it doesn't accept accept
whatever our relation except through
this a posteriori which depends on the
globally tied multinomial components
it's the nature wait
in the model itself it's not functional
time the mixer weight is a function of
time the multinomial is not a function
of time so here it is that's it it's got
a CT to it so the of it it's a
functional lives in the emotional so I
shot a function of campaign within each
or not it changes from analysis frame to
analysis frame that's increasing wall of
I mean the intentional environment
usually have the major face it's just be
sure the is the multinomial which
are which are constant yeah you're
you're motivating this in terms of
telephones each yes the nice
marginalization property to happen that
they're going to have some additional
channel effects no effects you're gonna
have noise do you have a plan for
dealing with that wow that's cool a
nastiness that comes with the telephone
signal which you don't get ok good it's
a brick wall ok so I am I am being I am
being quite naive and simplistic in this
particular example yes but in terms of
channel effects channel effects are not
such a serious issue so long as if you
give so long as you can effectively
model them as something that occurs as a
linear filter that occurs within one
analysis frame although i don't have the
figure on this on my slides it turns out
that if you think of the graphical model
for the whole process then currently you
have something that go all that happens
is that you end up having an additional
component which completely bypasses the
process the urns so it's a
multiplicative component so right now
what happens is you have the first step
which selects the urn and selects the
frequency that number could be
multiplied by a second step which
completely bypasses the arm and
multiplies the frequencies regardless of
which on the frequency was drawn from
and it's just a standard who can you can
use straight up belief propagation to
actually estimate that ok a dozen are
moving come get the inference of course
it would every time you add an
additional arrow it does
Scott complicate inference but it's
still nice you don't need you should
because directed highly directed yes and
we're talking about reconstitution just
look look nothing I could I mean have
not in this example I don't the process
is the same I am not really you know I
have a non have computed a histogram and
off which I've seen only some portion
what is my best guess for everything
else I have not seen that's all I'm
using the same how do you generate the
face faces is in this example okay here
this is this is kind of cute here I
actually did did some muck I computer i
computed a linear transformation between
the face for the upper frequencies in
the lower frequencies it turns out he
can do it in many different ways and
they all sound alike it's yes i have not
done ok you have a point over there you
have a very valid point because you use
the envelope j move above 2,000 years
but below let's say six five six ten to
the hills we need the face absolutely
and that is something i have not
addressed for the lower frequencies now
so you have a model for God's finger it
is for this yes that's this is very
speaker specific in this example so what
if you have a controllable over the band
newer selecting so do you have any
analysis of which bind is would mean
which will give more compression and
there is a lot that you're right but i'm
not i'm just looking at this blindly as
a multinomial process in which case you
know it has its drawbacks and i think
look at things like that for example
it's questionable whether i can infer a
lot about the lower frequencies
basically for if all I had with upper
frequencies and this is because if you
actually looked at the spectrum of any
particular basis right any particular
multinomial it's going to be it's going
to have very low all the high frequency
terms are going to have low
probabilities and the look low frequency
terms are going to have high
probabilities and it's hard to infer
high probability events based on low
probability events all the vice versa
not so hard so I cannot say are you in
choosing each earn at each instant I
don't know because this is all out there
there's no ground truth it should be
longer yes what is acting is the right
down of the wrong and there's no ground
truth you're right but then I have no
way of measuring it correct correct and
the hope is that if you act yes but the
hope is that you know if if you pull
things out the fact that there is a hole
over here might actually correlate to
the fact that there's something up there
are Sally Beauty you are absolutely
right so and that's where know what I
have not mentioned here is the
convoluted version over here i am
speaking of every time slice
independently and what brand well as the
convoluted version you're actually
looking at patches if you look dead
patches then you're actually going to
capture little bits of crack you know
transition information which are
supposed to be able to get you some of
that information in fact in our examples
you get much better reconstruction with
transition information and an additional
factor that i would mention towards the
end of the talk now the second problem
single channel speaker separation
paris's mentioned this but to rehydrate
you have two peoples in my example I'm
using two people speaking simultaneously
into one microphone and the goal is to
selectively separate out the signal for
a target speaker from the mixture or at
least enhance the signal for that
speaker now I must warn you that the
examples I show are not going to be as
dramatic and as beautiful as the example
status should not because i have i have
purposely chosen bad examples nor
because it purposely chosen good
examples because but because that's the
average example that's how things come
out the bottle now if i have two
speakers according to our model what
would i have i have speaker one with his
own set of urns and he just draws balls
from these urns at random within each
analysis frame and computes a histogram
I have speaker 2 also with his own set
of phones and he was bald and computes a
histogram but if I have a mixed signal
then i have this third guy who I called
the mad collar and his job in life is to
mess things up so the model for the
mixed signal is as follows at the first
level the matte color is going to select
one of these two guys he won't tell you
who and after having selected one of
these two guys this guy in turn goes in
selects an urn draws a ball carries can
read the information back to the fellow
on top who calls out the frequencies and
then you construct the spectrogram of
the numbers that he has called out the
point is that the total number of counts
of a particular frequency that he calls
out he is going to have contributions
from both speakers you may call out f1 a
thousand times and this has got of these
some number have come from this one and
some from this one and our job now is to
infer how many of these counts came from
the first model first guy and how many
came from the second guy enough
profession a user's earlier but for any
given frame you stop drawing when you
reach the right the energy of the
observation you the total count is a
total energy there's actually a scaling
factor involved which in maximum
likelihood solutions you can safely
ignore so are now this is the goal here
now as to dissing so what we have is the
distribution of the number that have
been finally called out and what we
would really like to do is to compute
the distribution for each of these
individual components we assume that we
have learned these urns from some
training data so what we really are all
we really need to estimate are the
mixture weights with which this person
selected these are these arts yes this
is is the same model as having all the
urns together being just one person
estimating some size in it before and
then just looking at this portion that
absolutely read them absolutely there is
a certain advantage to actually looking
at it from this two-level process but if
we ignore that advantage of it you did
not want to use it what you say is
absolutely right it will be exact same
on it there will be no difference so now
what we really want to do is to compute
the distributions for the two
individuals based on the combined
distribution and based on that because
what you really have is a histogram to
compute the histograms for the two
individual processes and wonderful we
can use expectation maximization as may
know your name let me just point it out
if I have all if I just throw all of
these arms into a single group right and
i have the caffeine and histogram input
all of you into a single group then
you're going to have only when you're
you're you're going to be sampled from
only one or no no I'm just going to good
cool I don't need know what the point is
I don't need the second level at all
this person could be simply selecting
arms we just need a secret idea of the
arms that's all you need to use
individual speakers not in every speech
to train them all over yes look yes and
no in the clean the keenest solution yes
in fact that it has some examples where
he does those on runtime where you know
if the second speaker begin speaking as
after the first speaker has begun
speaking it doesn't take a lot of
training data so for the first five
seconds you can actually train basis
from the first speaker and then
everything that remains goes to the
second speaker that's how we actually
separated the piano versus this thing
that out does really well so so now once
you compute the mix of its given the
urns and all these probabilities you can
say okay this is the sub distribution
that came from these urns and that in
fact is going to give you the spectrum
for that speaker and you can do and you
can separate things out if you actually
look at the graphical model for this you
have the speaker
the mad guy selecting the speaker who
selects and Han from which he selects
the frequency so the overall process for
the generation of a spectrum of a frame
is first you have the mad guys selecting
a frame then you have the speaker the
speaker selects and on and then selects
the frequency from beyond yes the
speaker lap your training question after
training he also have a similar model
like this right so to speak I dependent
transformation by mating based on some
frequency model okay and then you that's
how you create the speaker specific
mixture model correct so I'm trying to
figure out what how mathematically needs
to I deliver so training is mainly some
mixture of the frequencies and plus
traffic training yes I think after your
transformation based on a barrel are you
have a mean transformation right oh you
know I find transforms on cam sure and
one can find relationships you know this
is a very simple model but many similar
things so well separation you have my
simple formula which give you mixed
awaits once you have the mixture weights
we can actually separate the signals out
I'm running over time so I'm not going
to play out the example but it doesn't
sound that great let me want tell you
you typically get between three and six
DB of enhancement of the desired speaker
in a best case like the one that patty
showed you where you have the resonant
nice resident woman a nice resonant man
talking together you can get up to 10 DB
of improvement in the worst case when
they sort of sound alike you can get
negative improvements for one of the
speakers very basically pushing signals
from one speaker into the other the
competing see speaker is merely
suppressed they are not completely
eliminated because of the nature of the
model and sometimes you get a few
artifacts it is musical lines but
interestingly in these procedures you
actually get fewer artifacts than the
other masking based procedures where you
actually introduce holes now the results
as I said are not that great three to
six DB why the let's good useful to look
at the whole thing as in Plexus the
spectrum for any speaker is a point
within the same simplex for the speaker
now suppose I have a mixed signal from
two speakers let's say
speaker 1 had three arns three bought
the three blue dots and speaker 2 also
had three yawns with three red dots the
mixed signal is going to come from a
combination of six urns so all the
speaker one came from within this
simplex and speaker two came from within
this simplex the mixed signal came from
the largest simplex and what we are
really doing is to find out what the
contributions of the various corners are
to that point and ignoring the
contributions of the other speaker and
reconstructing the spectrum based on the
only on the contributions of the desert
of the target speaker the problem is
this region now this red simplex extends
all the way to these red points the blue
simplex extends all the way to the blue
points so any point that falls in this
region could have belonged either to the
red simplex or to the blue simplex how I
going to figure out which speaker at
went to or rather than balling on terms
save speaker a has an on with a certain
distribution of balls and there are some
combination of funds for speaker B which
give you the same distribution as this
urn for speaker a and if I have some
collection of balls from the urn for
speaker a I won't be able to say for
certain whether it came from that urn
for a or from that mixture of urns for B
and so what happens is the allocation of
energies to the two speakers can be
arbitrary which really ruins things now
here's a hacky solution we actually
explicitly take into account the fact
that there is this central part of ions
which cannot be distinguished and so
instead of training two separate sets of
urns one for each speaker is you train
three sets of parts one is specific to
the speaker the second the one each is
specific to each of the speakers and
then the central one is common to all
speakers and to generate the spectrum
speaker one could draw either from his
hands or from the common arts speaker to
get a good rider from his owns or the
common hands and now when you get a
mixed signal you actually compute the
mixture rates for all of the arts
including the common ions and the
specific ones for the two speakers and
then ignore not only the urns for the
other speaker but also the urns for the
cart also the commoners because you
really cannot be sure how they must be
allocated in fact you can do slightly
better than ignore
we can redistribute the energy from the
Sun spirit you know in calling to the
proportions of the energies in the other
ants but anyway if you do that here is
an example of what you get now this I
won't play the memory she icy water all
year so wait a minute it's a bit loud so
this is what I get using the regular
thing and let only the results are not
always great take that she actually
movies slicing water all year I'm trying
to pull out the mail guy Neil speech and
it hasn't come out but when I use the
other process let's go to movie here you
can see that the female speech is
significantly there you know reduce
because yeah it's just the mail you what
do you generate from the middle of years
no i don't i just ignore it I could
actually redistribute all the energy
from the middle on based on the
proportions of energies and the two side
arms and that should in principle give
us better it does in some examples
doesn't in other examples you use of the
lambs if I can get a much better yes
indeed and I let's mention that cue from
defining a poverty or prior probability
on the same place that's every way okay
yes the picture you showed with the
biggest region that's if you have so you
should let it to be playing with six
points but here you're really in doesn't
damage at all I'm waiting so there
there's no ambiguity is there there's it
wasn't going to get some some regions of
the simplex for speaker one will be
almost perfectly explained by the
simplex with speaker 2 and vice versa
regardless of the dimensionality it's
going to happen they are not because
you're not you know these are this is
not an l2 space its scale so anyway
prior information there we go what we
actually have is a simplex for the
speaker and the sequence of spectra is
actually going former forming a
trajectory through it now the points
every spectrum is one point in the
simplex but it's where the points may
not be uniformly distributed
across the simplex some regions may be
more populated that others may be less
populated that / may may not be
populated at all and we can take
advantage of this for example in the
same figure over here that I had earlier
if we know that this region is common to
both simplex is but speaker 1 fear was
this region where a speaker to flow
really favors this region then if a
point falls here you're perfect it's
perfectly okay to simply allocate it to
speaker 1 because there we applaud the
probability that you will make an error
is fairly small so if you are willing to
account for this sort of a prior then
instead of modeling the whole thing as a
mixer multinomial you actually model it
as a as a deliciously Polya process
where you have a prior British Lee
distribution which decides you know how
we are going to actually generate a
point within the simplex and then you
have a second process which actually
says how we are going to combine the
middle but the corners and the net and
the third level which actually computes
the histogram the prior probability
distribution for this distribution of
points within the simplex we will assume
is a delicious late here are some
examples of what that might look like in
a three-cornered simplex this for
example says that points are more likely
to occur over here then over here this
is you know all of these regions that
will more likely than this corner and so
on and so now we will actually use a
maximum a posteriori estimator where we
also use the delicious a prior in
computing the mixture weights the
proportions to which the various corners
must be combined to generate a mixed
point and then of course we do the same
thing we ignore the stuff that doesn't
belong to the target speaker to
reconstruct the signal the formulae look
a lot like what we had earlier so this
is the nice part of the whole framework
that no matter what you do the formula
don't get more complicated they all look
fairly simple except that over here when
you use pliers you're going to get one
magic number which tells you how much
you're going to trust the prior over
watch is over the data and you get the
second set which is the deliciously
parameter which you have to learn from
the training data again I have an
example here now now a single
relationally distribution is only
computes a single mode
it says that there is but one mode
within the whole simplex and this is not
really a very good model if you think of
it you still manage to get maybe half a
day be your one DB improvement when you
do this it's not a lot you get a minor
improvement rather than show you the
various examples i'm going to show you
this is what i get using both the
regular process this is what i get when
i use the duration of pliers you can
look at the spectrum you can see the
respect are in fact different and i
managed to successfully throw away a lot
of the spectrum which belongs to the
other speaker and only play out the
different signals to see what has been
reduced i had already washed over all
here so a lot of them this is primarily
the male speaker which has got being
removed so the signal has a lot more of
the females become you don't have to
just model static distributions you can
actually model the whole trajectory
using an hmm or you can actually use a
mixed mixture additionally priors and
they will all help the final topic this
is a slight this is slightly off the
trajectory that I've been following in
the rest of the presentation we'll talk
about sparse representations now in our
in our model the ants representing yes
yes but are almost we won't use a
minimum zero norm notation here we will
actually use minimum entropy yes we're
going to mention it it's look like that'
the model that you're describing with
their should hire etc it's a it's also
called it text later okay stabilize work
um the very nice thing about that is
that it's been extended to using eurasia
processes and so that's wonderful okay
yes and that perfect and that's and that
is the wonderful part of the whole
process the whole formulation that we
have in that we just sit back and let
the text guys do their work and then we
borrow the results and stick it in and
so and they do it
in last year's on oops there's actually
a paper which lacks the deliciously a
process as a trajectory in the simplex
so it also mathematics are all very
straightforward you don't need David
bleh to work it out for you you know it
takes half a day to work the whole work
it out end to end right so anyway this
fast representations are urns represent
basics now what we speak off and we want
a sparse representation is that we want
to explain each spectrum using the
smallest number of bases in ballin on
terms we want to say that inaud when the
person is generating the spectrum put a
particular frame he may have a hundred
ohms at his disposal but for that frame
we want him to use the smallest number
of funds it's best if he uses only one
on and brought all of us balls from that
one urn that's the step that's the zero
Norma definition except there's a
different way of looking at it that we
don't really need to think of it in
terms of using the smallest number of
parts we have a mixture weight
distribution over the urns and we can
say we want to minimize the entropy of
this distribution which gives you the
same result the significance is it
forces each of the bases to represent as
much spectral information as possible if
you don't enforce the sparseness
constraint then things can break up i
have an example here so here i have
three spec you know three figures that
are supposed to represent spectra you
might have one which looks like this
thus our other spectrum looks like this
and the third looks like this and if I
just train three bases I could train
these three bases and I can use these
bases combine these bases to reconstruct
the spectra with zero error with the one
the one thing that I need to use at
least two bases bases to reconstruct
anyone spectrum in fact there are many
many there are many unlimited number of
solutions unlimited number of ways in
which I can get three bases which can
all be combined to give the spectrum
with zero error but there's no guarantee
that any of these will make sense
whereas if I use a sparseness constraint
then this is what I would get as the
basics because in the sparseness
constraint I want to use the smallest
number of bases to generate the spectrum
and if I
do that this is the only possible answer
meaning one of the bases has got to be
this the second has to be this and the
third has to be this and now the
difference here is that when you do this
each of the bases themselves carries a
lot more spectral information in terms
of far yes it's not exactly the same but
they're related this is a minimum
entropy a sort of looking at it from a
que el distance saw Yeah right there is
an l 0 with a related minimum entropy is
much more tractable you know David you
know Donna who has what like 200 people
is trying to handle the l0 nom and he
hasn't gotten to the end of it whereas
if you throw in an entropy Tomic falls
out when I sit with the chin then you
can do something yes but I use entropy I
don't have to do any of that it just
falls out okay so here you know to
compute the spectrum for any given
analysis frame basically I mix I have a
probability distribution over the ants
and then I have a probability of the
frequency given the urn and I'm
combining all of these now if I want to
say that the representation must be
sparked then I want to say that the
probability of an urn must be 0 for a
large number of urns that way i am using
the smallest number of runs possible to
compute the spectrum alternately i can
say that the probability distribution of
which i am picking the urns must have
the smallest entropy and you can
actually formulate that all very nicely
this is the standard formulation that we
use when we actually compute all
parameters this is a maximum likelihood
formulation where we actually try to
maximize the fit between the data and
the model now to minimize the entropy of
our mixture weights we just throw in an
additional penalty within the same
formulation there's nothing it's exactly
the same except there's a penalty term
it says this must be minimized jointly
with the maximization of the other other
objective function and arithmetic for
this fortunately is textbook it's all
been worked out by Matthew branch so we
don't really have to work very hard at
it
but here are some results this is on
spectra now this is I haven't used the
log color maps so the figures don't come
out and that's clear but this is the
basic spectrogram for a signal I've
computed it appears even more washed out
on the screen but it has this is the set
of basis the x-axis represents the basis
index the y-axis represents the
frequency and this represents the manner
in which i have combined the bases the
x-axis represents time the y-axis
represents the basis index of this y
axis and this x axis are the same and
the more the number of dots over here in
this picture the more the number of
bases and actually using to reconstruct
the spectrogram now if I do the same
thing using a minimum entropy criterion
you'll find that this one is actually
very spot you're not using the bases a
whole lot so you're getting a much
sparser decomposition in terms of the
bases and correspondingly although you
can't make out if you actually compared
this basis figure to this you would find
that each of the bases here is much much
more spectrally rich than the bases up
here we can extend the whole minimum
convoluted entropy learning approach to
the convoluted versions of plc a just
just a result based on that now this is
the figure the parish sure except this
is yesterday I think this is just the
black black with the gray scale version
and you have a collection of faces and
what we try to estimate was one
convoluted basis which must be repeated
as many times as possible to reconstruct
the whole figure and when you do so this
is the average it says that the figure
is basically a repetition of this image
but when it tries to locate the figure
it's not very sure instead of giving you
pinpoint you know locations it actually
gives you these fuzzy blobs well it says
you know I think the face is somewhere
in this region and each part has a
different probability whereas if you
actually use the minimum entropy version
each spot is almost a pinprick it knows
exactly where the face must go so I
don't have any audio examples for this
but generally sparse replicated
representations derive much more
complete base
and this in particular is very useful
because now it means we can actually
learn our whether it be for audio or
video actually spectrally consistent
segments which actually makes sense and
so we can expect to get much better
performance for both bandwidth expansion
a speaker separation or any other
decomposition based processing so in
conclusion we have described various
latent variable decomposition based
techniques for analyzing audio and video
data and we have derived these from
techniques normally applied for text
analysis which is great we let the text
guys do all the work and then we just
take it and there are several very
promising avenues actually remains work
in progress thank you